long does it take to feel if you have antibodies to brain tissue. Okay, so there's a test done
that we have done on lots of people called the Syrex 7x array 7x. That's a test for neuronal
antibodies. So the main neuronal components that you could develop antibodies are tested in an array.
If you have antibodies to neuronal tissue, it can affect more than just your brain because you have
neuronal components outside of the brain and spinal cord. So let's say if you have antibodies to
synapsid, which is protein, that is found in your brain, in your neuronal synapsis, where
nerves come together, you could say the joints of a nerve. That's got affect perforal nerves as well.
But typically we're doing that test on people that might have upper motor neuron issues, maybe
like brain type issues, inflammation, maybe early dementia or just forgetfulness or weird symptoms
that could be related to pride alone or temporal alone interference. So if you do, if a part,
we do run that test and the person does have positive antibodies, how long does it take to heal? Well,
you're really, it's your lifetime. So it's not a matter of magically making antibodies go away.
So typically in this stage of with brain issues is that you could get inflammation in the brain,
that could be from a variety of sources, could be from a pathogen like Lyme disease or strep or
something like that, could be from trauma, from concussions, you get a car accident, it causes
the trauma causes inflammation in the brain to just emotional stress to all sorts of different
things can cause inflammation in the brain. So everybody gets that at different times,
they get certain levels of inflammation in the brain. And definitely with people who have a cancer
diagnosis, if they're taking medications, that is a big cause of inflammation in the brain.
That is, quote, unquote, chemo-brain. Chemo-brain is when you're on a harsh medication like chemotherapy.
Those medications can cross the blood brain barrier and causes inflammation in the brain.
Well, prolonged inflammation in the brain activates certain type of cell in your brain called
your microglial cells. The microglial cells are really the scavenger, quote, unquote, macrophages of
the brain. It's part of the immune system of the brain. It's part of the cleaning out of the brain.
They move around the brain with their little tentacles and grab on to inflammatory cytokines,
grab on to pathogens so they help get things out of the brain and clean up the brain.
Well, prolonged inflammation can damage those microglial cells so they can be damaged and stay in
what's called a primed state. So primed microglial cells are damaged microglial cells. They don't
work the same way anymore. And they can affect all sorts of things. So I'm explaining this because
there's a progress versus it just doesn't get antibodies to brain tissue. They get inflammation and
then they get primed microglial cells and then they end up developing antibodies to neural tissue.
So you have to kind of walk backwards and try to heal a person with antibodies to neural tissues.
Your decrease in inflammation is your biggest step. Try to heal the brain, stimulate neurogenesis,
stimulate neuroplasticity, brain exercises. You will you ever have those antibodies to
brain tissue go away. Maybe. But again, the antibodies to neural tissue are just a sign that there's
damage there. If you don't do anything, you just let it progress. That's when it's going to progress
to MS or other demyelinated diseases. It's going to progress to neuronal inflammation. That is
that is unstoppable and you're going to end up with Parkinson's and and full blood Alzheimer's.
So it's not really how long does it take to heal. It's what do you need to do to move towards healing?
Once you have that damage and you have antibodies to brain tissue, you're just constantly working on
decreasing inflammation of the brain. It's not something to take lightly. You have to be active
and be working on decreasing inflammation of the brain and healing the brain. Hope that helps.